hi I'm hollow five six one my name is
Elway no and I created a viral song on
tick-tock this is that story so my life
changed in October 2019 but I'm gonna go
back we just moved from New York My
partner and I My partner is away no
Grammy award-winning producer record
producer our producer a lot of people I
produced for Shaggy sting a whole lot of
hip-hop
I scored a lot of films as well like
there's a series on Netflix called the
rapture I'm the composer for that whole
series I worked in advertising I was
laid off for my last job so I was job
hunting for about six months five to six
months and away no is working he's doing
his thing and he gets a project from an
agency called Movers & Shakers
they said hey we need this song and we
need to do it for health cosmetics and
it's gonna be jumping and I'm like fine
let's do it the winos like asking me
questions and about cuz he doesn't wear
makeup and all of that and I'm like oh
you know well they want to use something
using eyes lips face and I'm like oh
that makes sense because elf stands for
our eyes lips face no mater I made a
little beet something really super
simple some minimal that would you know
you know catch that youthful attention
of those kids on tik-tok Elena took most
of the majority like he like started
framing the words well as he was
grabbing them to me because he doesn't
really wear makeup some of them didn't
make sense so I helped him with that
like girls wouldn't do this or you know
even when you say like do that thing
with your eyes like we had to think
about okay what is the thing like we
imagined like winking or whatever they
do a demo they sent it to the agency and
team and they come back and they're like
love the song they're like ah yeah so
yeah email vocal on this I like alright
he's kind of wondering like who's gonna
be on this song I need a female voice
like really quick
well there's me who's doing nothing but
job hunting so I turned to Halle I
looked at Halle and said you're gonna
have to record this song for me so I'm
like it's demo it's not like it's gonna
go anywhere
you know I finished a few sessions
earlier and I was pretty pretty tired
but you know I knew I had to get this
done it was like Thursday going into
Friday and Halle was like kind of
falling asleep because I've been waiting
all day and Elena wakes me up and he's
like okay we gotta get this done
the song's due on Monday record the song
coaching her through it and then the
energy kind of dipped down you know it's
Nate and she's like yo y'all need
heightened yeah that was really like a
moment you know like it's it's it was a
real moment that's why I kind of stuck
out for everybody in a song we go
through the song all night you know I
was being gentle and nudging because
it's my first time recording it's a
lengthy process but necessary one and it
kind of works out you know he sends it
off that Friday we come back on Monday
and same thing we love the song who's
this new artist we love her energy you
know what's her name whatever and we're
just like um she's this up-and-coming
artist I don't have a rap name I've
never rapped before like this is brand
new it way knows like okay we need to
have a name for you or you can put your
real name out I'm job hunting I'm not
putting my real name out there everybody
went to their hometown I was like Halle
five six one is from Florida you know
Palm Beach to be exact so you know
that's what I five six one comes in and
they're like that sounds pretty good and
Halle is now a rap artist
meanwhile I'm still job hunting mind you
so we finish the song we send the
information to the team base since their
client elf cosmetics they get everything
ready for their campaign and they put it
on tick-tock
I finally get a job you know once elf
cosmetics put that song on tick-tock I
was just on I was glued to it you know
we see the videos come in everyone doing
their rendition of izip space within the
next like 2-3 days we see the numbers
skyrocketed I was in New York in the
studio looking at tick tock refreshing
refreshing refreshing and then the
numbers kept going up first hundreds of
thousands which I freaked out then
millions all right where we got now boom
1 billion views and then we started
seeing celebrities do it I wake up one
morning and I see Reese Witherspoon do
the challenge I'm hype then I see Terry
Crews then we seen Howie Mandel Jessica
Alba James Charles he did one and then
Patrick Starr did one Liz oh and I love
Liz oh I'm freaked out this is amazing
Ellen and I see a soundbite that she's
doing the challenge on her show and she
actually has a video that's on her
tick-tock as well as on the show when
everybody in the world open their phone
on tick-tock it was the front page and
I'm like wait what's happening right now
the song is going up we now extends a
song to a full length song and then I
played it for shaggy I've live a bunch
of other people and they're like oh like
this is what it actually blows up on
Spotify over a million views plays per
month on Spotify you know then I'm
coming from oh you have no place from
among from Spotify this artist we've
literally made up a name elf cosmetics
like there's had so much good reception
like this is a groundbreaking thing
let's celebrate by doing a music video
and I'm like am I not to be a celebrity
and I love
right now she's always been this person
she's been this person the whole life
she just didn't know she was this person
I just started my job and I had to kind
of lie funny thing is where we shot the
video is literally maybe about five
blocks away from what I worked and we're
doing the shoot it's going well and
there's a part where we're actually have
to go on the roof we're at the roof
doing the shots and there's this news
helicopter flying above our head and I'm
freaking out because I'm like I really
hope like my boss doesn't like turn on
the news and see that I'm at a photo
shoot and I'm actually hiding underneath
the curtain the music video was amazing
you can actually catch it on elf
cosmetics website and then we started
getting calls from almost every record
label imaginable and it waaaay knows
like okay let's get this moving so we
get a team together and we shopped
around deals trying to see who who's the
best fit for us
Republic Records came along you know we
did a deal over there and just been
rockin ever since we've got a ton of new
music coming and everyone's like okay
you know this is where like life changes
for everyone like where they tour and
all of that and it really just came to a
crossroads of like what I'm gonna do
next for a long time I always ask
they're like what is it that you love
doing what is your your gift was your
talent what is that thing that you love
to do but she's just don't you know say
like you know when people are just dope
but they might not even know they're
dope but you as a visionary can be like
you know see that they're dope you just
got a nudge damn you know I mean you
don't want to be old sitting like okay
what would I do with my life like what
well what would have happened so I took
the plunge and I actually did not lie to
my boss this time and I told him that
leaving to focus on my music career now
she's a full-time artist you know she
just didn't know now she is
[Music]